OF THE TWO IS ENERGY AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND SERGEANTS WILL
CALL SOME OF THE AFTER MEMBERS
AS WELL AS THE PRESENTERS BEFORE
WE MOVE TO THE AGENDA I HAVE A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO MAKE WE WILL HAVE. TO
REMEMBER GIPSON TEMPORARILY. AND
SOME. FONG REPLACING SOME MEMBER
BAUER CAN ON OUR COMMITTEE TODAY
WELCOME THOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WHEN THEY ARRIVE. WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR PERCENT AND OR USE A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
CALL NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FOUR. THREE GIRLS SINCE THE
NINETIES BELIEVES IN ENERGY
WEAPON I. AND YOU GET ON THE
SCREEN YOU ARE HAPPEN ANY
PROBLEMS FEEL FREE TO CALL PART
COMEDIAN NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE
NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT. I OF OUR BE
THERE TO BE HEALTH THEY WE HAVE
SEVEN MASTERS. ON THE ONE IS ON
THE CONSENT. AS WE PROCEED WITH
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES. TO ENSURE. WE
MAINTAIN ORDER. AND RUN
FISHERMEN IF YOU'LL BELIEVE ME
JUST ASK OUR MISTER BERMAN. WILL
TELL YOU. THAT THERE ARE. BEFORE
DOES THE MONIES THEM TO FOUR
MINUTES. TOTAL OF TWO MINUTES
EACH PERSON. TWO MINUTES IN
SPORTS TWO MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION. PRETTY THIS AND
WITNESSES ON A MEASURE ONLY
STATE YOUR NAME POSITION.
AFFILIATIONS WE WILL LIMIT TIME
FOR THOSE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
TO TWENTY MINUTES PER BILL. IF
YOU SEE THIS TIME FOR THE
MEASURE AND IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN. YOU MAY SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY THROUGH EMAIL AND THE
ADDRESSES ON THE WEBSITE ARE
MAINTAIN A DECORUM. DURING THE
YEAR AS IS CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO DISRUPTED MAY BE
MOVED. IN THE ROOM AND MORE
EATING SERVICES BOMB. SO SIX.
WELL CAN WAIT TILL WE HAVE. LAST
SEE IF THEY ARE ANY MEMBERS. OF
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY WE'LL HAVE A
**** REJECTED I'M HAPPY HAPPY
RIGHT.
THANK FOR YOUR TIME I AM VERY AB
TWENTY ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
YOU'RE IN TROUBLE NOT BE HERE
TODAY. THIS BILL MILLER VERY.
THE REPRODUCTION AB. WITH ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES SO CAN'T ISSUE WE
HAD TO. AB THREE SIX EIGHT
SACRAMENTO WILL TELL VOTERS HAVE
A RIGHT. TWENTY CAN WATCH IT BOB
TALKING. YEAH TWICE A YEAR- AND
WOULD CALIFORNIA ON PURPOSE
DAYLIGHT TO. SWITCHING OUR
CLOCKS OF DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME
TWICE THE IS AN OUTDATED THAT IS
HAS A HEALTH. AND WELL BEING
IT'S TIME TO END IT WELL OFFICE
ON STANDARD YOUR IS ONE SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF IT AND THE- STAYING IN
INDIA HIS TOP. TO MAKE IT.
BERMAN DALY SAVINGS TIME WHICH
CAN RESULT PROFIT. AND BROUGHT
OFFER NET ENERGY SAVE A COMPACT
. PROVIDE GREAT BONE TO TOWARD
INDUSTRY LOCAL PER. AB Q. EIGHT
SIX STATE IS ALSO IN CONFORMITY
WITH FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN CONGRESS AND PASS
OUT OF THIS U. S. SENATE WITH A
PART IN SUPPORT. OURS OTHERS.
PASSED WHAT IS. THE RIGHT
SAVINGS TIME PERMANENT AND ARE
WAITING FOR FEDERAL APPROVAL NOT
A SINGLE STATE HAS INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO MAKE STANDARD
TIME IF YOU CURRENT TIME. THIS
BILL HAS PASSED OUT OF. GO
BIPARTISAN PART AND FOR THIS
REASON THAT STATED ABOVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSESTO BE NO-
MISTER CHAIRMAN WIN OKAY ARE
THERE ANY- INDIVIDUALS- CALLING
IN MISTER OR MRS MODERATOR. MR
MRS. FIVE FIVE I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OKAY WE'LL CALL
YOU UP AND MEANT. VETERANS OF
SOME. SO NO ONE TO TESTIFY OR TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ON THE-
TELEPHONE WILL ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY INDIVIDUALS THAT PRESENT I
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. I WANNA- CALL UP THE IN
THE GERMAN WHO SET UP A- WHO IS
OPPOSING THE MEASURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HE'S NOT THE AUTHORS OF DON'T
BEAT HIM UP TOO BAD RIGHT PLEASE
. PLEASE THANK YOU. IF YOU. ARE
IN SYSTEMIC FONG CAN HEAR ME YES
SIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MY NAME IS JAY AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NONPROFIT SAVE
CENTER TIME OR IF. WE WERE WITH
SUCH DOCTORS TEACHERS AND
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME EXTENSIONS SUCH AS
THIS BILL AND IN SUPPORT OF
PERMANENT STANDARD TIME- AND I
MYSELF AM A RESIDENT OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU WOULD OPPOSE
THIS BILL. AND WRECK IT'S
AMENDMENT TWO MINUTE SANDARD
TIME. STANDARD TIME IS THE
NATURAL TIME DEFINED BY THE SUN
IT IS THE REAL TIME- THIS IS
LIGHT IN MORNING AND EVENING FOR
OPTIMAL HEALTH SAFETY AND- RT.
DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME IS. TO WAIT. IN THE THEY WILL. BE IN THE
WRONG FOR PUBLIC POLICY IF
YOU'RE TO ASK YOUR- WOULD THEY
LIKE THEIR ALARM CLOCKS SET AN
HOUR EARLY ALL WINTER THEY WOULD
SAY NO BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD FORCE THEM TO DO IT WOULD
BE SUCH AS- CLOCK IN THE- SENATE
- EIGHT. DEBATE AND UNTIL EIGHT
FIVE IN THE MORNING- IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE HERE A
COMPARISON PHOTOGRAPHS SHOWING
YOU. WHAT WENT. IT WOULD LOOK
LIKE. THIS IS ANAHEIM AT SEVEN
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING STANDARD
TIME VERSUS THE DARK DAYLIGHT
TIME. THIS IS- TO HATCH A P.
THIS IS THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO AB
DARK PAST EIGHT O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING IN THE WINTER WITH
PERMANENT DAYLIGHT TIME. THIS
WAS TRIED BEFORE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES A HUGE AND POPULAR IT
LITERALLY KILL CHILDREN. THIS IS
A PHOTOGRAPH OF CHILDREN WAITING
FOR BUS TO SCHOOL IN THE MORNING
IN THE DARK. MEMBERS OF MEDIEVAL
SUPPORT OF START SCHOOL LATER
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS BILL WOULD
REVERT THOSE BENEFITS BY FORCING
PEOPLE TO GO TO SCHOOL OR WORK.
IN THE DARK- IT'S THIS IS ABOUT
IT THIS IS UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE. DAYLIGHT TIME
INCREASED ENERGY CONSUMPTION
BECAUSE GOING TO WAKE PEOPLE UP
IN THE MORNING THEY TURN UP HEAT
BECAUSE IT PULLED. IT'LL WAIT A
LATE. THERE IS OR MORE ARM A-
THAT'S THERE IS OWN INTO NOT
HAVE. DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME AT
ALL WHEN INDIAN INTRODUCED
DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME IT INCREASE
THEIR ENERGY CONSUMPTION BY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. PER YEAR. IT
WAS INCOME STATED THAT THERE ARE
NO STATES CONSIDERING STANDARD
TIME THAT IS NOT TRUE I COULD
NAME AT LEAST A DOZEN. I'M
MISSIONS UP UP OBSERVE. TIME
MEXICO'S CONSIDER. CENTER TIME.
THIS BILL IS OPPOSED BY THE
NATIONAL SAFETY COUNCIL THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY SO IN THE
CALIFORNIA. C. EIGHTY I. AND I
THERE'S- COMMAND- THIS OF
MEASURE- THAT PERMITS THEM TIME
IS QUICKEST AND FEDERALLY PRE
APPROVED WAY. TO END DAYLIGHT
SAVING THAT TO AND CLICK CHANGE
AND I THE GAME BIRD IS THAT YOUR
LEG. POSE THIS BILL ENCOURAGES
AMENDMENT TO STANDARD TIME THANK
YOU VERY WELL I'M GONNA ASK THE
MODERATOR AFTER ONE. TO THIS.
OKAY. BUT THE NEXT QUESTION WAS
DO WE HAVE MODERATE. THE TAKING
A BREAK ANYONE IN THE IN THE IN
THE ROOM HERE WOULD LIKE TO-
TESTIFIED OPPOSITE NAME
ORGANIZATION. OKAY I UNDERSTAND
A DOCTOR WAS TO CALL IN TO SPEAK
WERE WERE WERE OF OUR GROUP. IN
THIS MY FIRST UPSTAIRS IS NOT
RESPONDING OKAY SIR- MISTER
MODERATOR MISTER MISTER. MADAM
MODERATE MOUNTAINS HELLO YES
SENATE HEARING YES. MY NAME IS
DR ANOOP K. PARK AND- I AM
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA I WILL BE THERE IN
PERSON I AM- BOARD CERTIFIED
PSYCHIATRIST TYLER DALTON TRIED
BY A DIRECT HIT MEDICINE
SPECIALIST AND ALSO THE
ATTRIBUTES THAT. I'M NOT REPORT
PENDING THE CALIFORNIA OF THE-
WE- DR IN ORDER IN. DONALD ALL
RIGHT GOD LEWIS AND ALSO THE SAN
DIEGO THANK AT THE PROVIDE THE
FIVE AND BOTH MEN PROBLEM THE
PSYCHIATRIST MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND THE CHILD
PSYCHIATRIST ON THE STATEMENTS
AND TAKING ACTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
IN OAKLAND THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ALSO THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM THEY WANTED TO SPEAK TO
AN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- I'LL
SEE GREENBACKS DIES ANYONE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
YEAH I'M GOING TO JUST. BUT I'VE
I'VE BEEN CONFLICTED ABOUT THIS
I'M JUST TELL YOU STRAIGHT OUT-
KIND OF BACK AND FORTH. UP BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THE NATURAL CYCLE OF
THINGS. IS NOT DAYLIGHT SAVINGS
TIME AND I THINK THE OPPOSITION
MAKES. A SIGNIFICANT POINT OUR
BODIES ARE ATTUNED TO WHEN THE
SUN COMES UP AND WHEN THE SUN
GOES DOWN. ARTIFICIALLY IT SEEMS
TO ME SETTING THE CLOCK THAT
ACTUALLY WARS AGAINST. THE
NATIONAL RHYTHM OF LOS. SO I'M
THAT LAY OFF ON THIS- I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT NOW- NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO AND THIS IS A SORT OF
A- PAROCHIAL THING WITH ME
BECAUSE OF THIRTY YEARS OF
OWNING AND OPERATING RADIO
STATIONS. AND I KNOW THAT THE
BROADCAST INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
SILENT ON ALL OF THIS. BUT THE
REALITY IS. THAT THE THREE
LETTER CALL STATIONS CAME J. THE
OTHER CALL. THIRD IN AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IN ORDER TO GET
MIKE TIME BROADCASTING HAS TO
LOWER THEIR POWER I WANT RADIO
STATIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND IDAHO
. IF THIS BILL WERE IN FACT.
PAST THE REALITY IS THAT MY
RADIUSED I'VE SOLD BY STATIONS A
FEW YEARS BACK BUT- THE REALITY
IS. THAT DURING THE DAY A. M.
DRIVE TIME YOU MENTION UNTIL
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHT FIFTEEN OR
EIGHT THIRTY. I WOULD BE
BROADCASTING AT A THOUSAND
WATTS. INSTEAD OF TEN THOUSAND
WATTS. THIS IS THIS IS THIS
CREATES A REAL BURDEN. FOR THESE
M. STATIONS THAT HAVE TO LOWER
THEIR POWER IN SOME INSTANCES
THESE RADIO STATIONS HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED WATCH AT NIGHT. AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BROADCAST.
TILL NINE O'CLOCK EIGHT THIRTY
AND LOSE. THERE CITY LICENSE
COVERAGE JUST ABOUT. SO YEAH I
KNOW IT'S PAROCHIAL UNKNOWN
THERE'S NOT OPPOSITION FROM
BROADCAST BUT AS A THIRTY YEAR
BROADCASTER UP REDDIT REDDIT
STATIONS ARE GOING TO BE A AND A
AND- AND PARTICULAR THE
DAYTIMES. YOU'RE A LOT OF
DAYTIME STATION TO GO OFF THE-
SO THEN I CAN BE A SIGN ON.
MORNING MAKE YOUR YOU'RE
DESTROYING ESSENTIALLY THEIR
THEIR PRIME TIME SPUR FOR
REVENUE. SO I'M CONFLICTED ABOUT
IT FOR BOTH THOSE REASONS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY I THINK THE
NATURAL RHYTHM OF LIFE BUT LOOK
MY LIFE IS LIVED AROUND THE SUN
COMES UP WHEN THE SUN GOES DOWN.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE CLOCK
SAYS. ALL RIGHT SO I CAN'T GET
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS. I'M GONNA
LAY OFF OF IT- ALLY I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE WOULD DO WELL WHAT'S
BEEN. SUGGESTED BY THE
OPPOSITION THAT THANK YOU. DR-
START WITH A CO WORKER. AND
SINCE NONE THANK YOU I WAS A CO
AUTHOR IN REGIONAL BILL SINCE
THEN. GOT A LOT OF INPUT. FROM
PEOPLE WHO STUDY OUR NATURAL
RHYTHMS. AND CRITICALLY IN THE
WINTER. THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE
CONCERNED. ABOUT PEOPLE WAKING
UP BEFORE THE SUN COMES UP. AND
THE EFFECT THAT THIS HAS ON
THEIR BIO RHYTHMS. SO I'M GOING
TO BE SOME. STANDARD TIME YOU.
R. THANK YOU. RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS- MR PENSION- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE VICE CHAIR IN
THE DOCTOR PARKS- TESTIMONY-
MATTHEOS FOR THE BILL BUT
SERVING- AS A- REPRESENTATIVE
SOME RESIDENTIAL- ANSWERED I
WILL RELAY THAT INFORMATION- TO
THE AUTHOR- WITH BATTLESHIPS- IN
HIS BED BATH. I KNOW THAT YOUR
CONCERNS WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AS A BILL WITH IS
THIS COMMITTEE TO MOVE FORWARD
ON BUT ONLY THAT BRITAIN TEAM
WILL BURST- CHANGE INTO THIS NEW
TIME. TENSION ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT IS CURRENTLY PENDING
CONGRESS HAS ALREADY PASSED THE
U. S. SENATE TO FOLLOW IN THIS
METHODOLOGY AND SO IT I NOTICED
THE AUTHORS WILL TO FOLLOW
METHODOLOGY HAVE CONFIRMED A
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND
I MYSELF- HAVE- TACKLED IN THIS
ISSUE AND DONE SOME RESEARCH IT
WAS. A RESEARCH STUDY BY USC
HANNAH AND TAKE BUT IT'S WHERE I
GRADUATE FROM USC'S OWN
DISORDERS MAY NOT BE THAT GOOD-
THE HEAD TALK ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OF STOPPING THE TIME SWITCH AND
I SEE THERE IS OPPOSITION. AND
PRO ON BOTH SIDES SO WELL TO ME
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR POINTS HERE
TOM PROTECT DATA THE AUTHOR ON
TWITTER AND WITHOUT A I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MR THANK
YOU WILL TAKE A- ACTION MOTION
WHEN WE WILL CALL BERMAN. AND
APPROPRIATE. FOR OR- THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. THE STATING YOUR
YOUR POSITION- SUMMER WORK. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN YOU EVER TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND DO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE MOST AND-
ENERGY GOALS IN THE WORLD.
PERCENT RENEWABLE ENERGY AND OF
COURSE 1100% CARBON FREE
ELECTRICITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
WATER ST HAS MADE GAINS IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY DEPLOYMENT
DIFFICULT BARRIER TO CONSUMER
ASIAN DO EXIST FOR EXAMPLE
PERCENT OF ALL MORNING HOLD OF
ANY PERCENT OF LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ARE RENTERS WHICH IN
NEARLY ANY REASON ON OR- OTHER.
MAYBE FULL OR HOLDEN. DUE TO
PHYSICAL EXCESSIVE SEAT LIMITED
. STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES OR
FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS ONE WAY
THE STATE CAN ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES IS THROUGH THE USE OF
COMMUNITY RENEWABLE PROJECTS
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY SMALLER
SCALE SOLAR INSTALLATIONS BUILT
ON LANDFILLS FORMER INDUSTRIAL
SITES ARE SMALL PRIVATE PARCELS
OF LAND. THESE PROGRAMS OPERATE
IN TWO WAYS CONSUMERS. AS TO
LOWER COSTS FOR POWER PAYING A
MONTHLY FEE AND THEN EARNING
CREDITS ON THEIR ELECTRICAL
BILLS OR CUSTOMERS MAY PURCHASE
SHARES PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR
ENERGY NEEDS. ON A SET AMOUNT OF
A COMMUNITY RENEWAL PROJECTS
POWER GENERATION CAPACITY. HOW
CAN YOU RENEWABLES ARE VERY
PRACTICAL COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS MORE CAL
MEANS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
OTHERWISE PEOPLE AT THE BENEFITS
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY ATTEMPTS A
COMMUNITY RENEWAL. IN FUTURE.
INDOOR SIMPLY NEAR SCOPE AND
RANGE THIS IS CREATED IS THE
NEW. MARKET GAP IN WHICH
UNDERMINES ITS ABILITIES TO
ACHIEVE ITS ENERGY EQUITY
PRIORITIES THIS BILL AB TWENTY
SIXTEEN CREATES A NEW PROGRAM TO
EXPAND RENEWABLE ENERGY ACCESS.
WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA INCREASE
NATION'S MOST EQUITY. MUNITY ALL
PRO IT'S BEEN TEN TO AVOID NUKE
TO RATEPAYERS AND REQUIRE
STORAGE FOR COMMUNITY SOLAR
PROJECTS IN ORDER TO EXPAND
SOLAR ACCESS AMONG NEARLY HELP
CALIFORNIANS YOU AND OR HAVE LOW
INCOMES ALSO BUILDING POWER
REPRESENTS. AGAINST EXPECT
MARKET FOR THE COMMUNITY
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROGRAMS SUCH
AS COMMUNITY SOLAR PLUS STORAGE
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS
CLIMATE GOALS TO PROVIDE WITNESS
TESTIMONY OF CHARLES CONGRESS
ALL DIRECTOR POLICYMAKER TERRY
AFFAIRS. COLIN FOR COMMUNITY
SOLAR. AT THE FIRST STOP
ATTORNEY WITH THE RE NETWORK.
THANK YOU BEFORE YOU START I'M
GOING TO JUST ANNOUNCES
APPARENTLY THE PHONES ARE WORK
AND SO FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
WATCHING RIGHT- OR ASK THEM TO.
IN COMMON THAT THEY MAY HAVE-
EMAIL THE EMAIL IS A LAPSE. AT
ALL FOR THE ORDER SAID WE'LL
KEEP CHECKING WITH THE MODERATE
AS A AS WE HEAR THAT BEFORE BACK
ON PLEASE. AND WE'VE- YES I'M
ACTUALLY A THE AS A CALL THE
ROLL SO WE CAN ESTABLISH RAPPORT
THANK YOU BYE BYE EDUARDO GARCIA
. EDUARDO GARCIA HERE PATTERSON
. PATTERSON HERE CARILLO CHEN
CHEN HERE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HERE FONG FONG HERE CRISTINA
GARCIA GIPSON GIPSON HERE HOLDEN
. MAYES MURATSUCHI CORK HERE
QUICK HERE REYES REYES HERE.
TAKING THAT'S EIGHT OKAY WE
ACQUIRE PLEASE PRESS WITNESS
THANK YOU CHAIR GARCIA AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORD FOR IT
GIVE ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY- MY NAME'S JOHN I'M
WITH THE COALITION YOU SO RIGHT
. YES IT THIS IS JIM WITH.
REMEMBER ORGAN THIS INCLUDING
THE FORMER AND NON- ENGAGED
COMPARED TO RENEWABLE ENERGY
MORE ARE THE COUNTRY. WHAT
CALPERS HAS BEEN A LEADER WITH
THE WINNER POLICY DEPLOYMENT
THAT IS FALLING SHORT IN ONE
AREA IN PARTICULAR COMMUNITY
RENEWABLES. THE SENATE REWARD AS
MENTIONED THIS IS LEFT A MASSIVE
GAP IN DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
PARTICIPATION OPPORTUNITIES
GENERALLY LIMITING IT TO ONLY
THOSE THAT OWN THEIR HOME OR
HAVE A SUITABLE PROPERTY OR
NANCY WHO. BROWN'S I WHICH ONE
COME READ. THERE ISN'T THE MOST
UNDER. NONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAMS IN EXISTENCE TODAY
CURRENTLY PROVIDE OR CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING THE COMPREHENSIVE AND
SCALABLE SOLUTIONS ENVISIONED IN
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN WHICH
WOULD CREATE ONE OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY NO MANAGER
PROGRAM COUNTRY BUT THE RIVER
BINDING TO CAL. SUPPRESSED
ENERGY. SIXTEEN MARKET DRIVEN.
CAR THE FACT THE PROGRAM THAT
PRIMARILY TARGETS PARTICIPATION
AND BENEFITS FOR LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS. ALSO PROVIDING IF YOU
WILL TO SUPPORT THEIR STATE
POLICY OBJECTIVES SUCH AS THE
NEW CONSTRUCTION SOLAR MAN IT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THE STATE'S
BUILDING CODE. THE PROGRAM WITH
ALL OF THE SWAKOP THINGS
DESCRIBERS TO PROJECTS BASED ON
THE TIME DIFFERENTIATED WHAT IT
COSTS VALUE WHICH WILL IN TURN
DRIVE DEPLOYMENT OF GENERATION
AT THE DIRTY SHOWERS OF THE YEAR
WHEN THE GREAT IS MOST AT RISK
OF RELY. TO THAT END. NEEDED
ALSO TEXAS SO SHOULD WITH THIS
WOULD BE COUPLE WITH ENERGY
STORAGE. LASTLY AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN WOULD GUARANTEE THE JOB
TO BE PAID A PREVAILING WAGES TO
BUILD THESE FACILITIES. THE LIST
OF ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL RANGING FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO
INDUSTRY LABOR AND RATEPAYER
ADVOCATES PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MERIT TO THESE CLAIMS ARE NOTE
THAT MISSING IN THE ANALYSIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
SAY HI WHICH IS. ALSO A
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THIS IS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER SHOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES. THIS COMMITTEES
HERBIE TALK QUITE A BIT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT OUR SOLAR ROOFTOP
SOLAR PROGRAMS HAVE LEFT A HUGE
SWATH OF CALIFORNIANS BEHIND.
THE NETMEETING PROGRAM HAS
PRODUCED TWELVE THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS WITH LESS THAN NINETY
MEGAWATTS OF THAT GOING TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A GREAT SOLUTION
IS COMMUNITY SOLAR BILL WILL GO
A LONG WAY WE HAVE A SIMILAR
BUILDINGWHERE THE SPONSOR OF
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL COME OVER
FROM THE SENATE TODAY WE THINK
IT IS COMPLEMENTARY NOT
NECESSARILY COMPETE COMPETING
WITH THIS BILL IT'S VERY TIGHTLY
FOCUSED ON THE LOWEST INCOME.
RATEPAYERS BUT THIS IS A REALLY
WELL THOUGHT OUT BILL THAT
DOESN'T CONTAIN CAUTIOUS IT IS
GOING TO HELP. GIVE THOSE FOLKS
WITH A MULTI FAMILY HOUSING AND
THOSE WHO RENT. AND DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SOLAR REVOLUTION
THAT ACCESS TO URGENT ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO WE KNOW THAT THE
PHONE IS IT WORKING A MASS TO
SEE IF ANYONE IN THE ROOM WANTS
TO COME FORWARD AND SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIAN WHITE ON BEHALF
OF CYPRESS CREEK RENEWABLES WE
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A SOLAR
CAN BE SOLAR PROGRAM IN LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS AND COMMITTEE AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU.
HOWEVER THE MILE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FUND AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HI RICK HOW MASON ON
BEHALF OF SAY HI THE CENTER FR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ETF BOTH SOLAR IN
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOE HENRY I WORK WITH
DIMENSION RENEWABLE ENERGY WE
ARE A NATION WIDE COMMUNITY
SOLAR DEVELOPER WE ARE VERY
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. HI NICK
FACE IN WITH TURNING POINT
ENERGY WERE ALSO AND NATIONAL
REVIEW PROJECT DEVELOPER WE'RE
IN A NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES BASED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE I.
N. THROUGH Z. ASCOLI IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. SAN OR
NAS. I'M TOLD THAT THE LINES ARE
BACK UP MISTER MODERATOR. THE
SMALLER. EACH WE ARE TAKING UP
SUPPORT POSITIONS THE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. AND IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK ON THAT ONE
THEN THERE AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE TO IN Q. THANK YOU FOR THE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OR LEN
AFTER BREAK ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC OF NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS TO A ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AYE DADDY FROM
PASADENA CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN. JUST
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE TO MORE
THAN KEEP UP. IT WILL GO TO MY
PRETTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
I'M CHRISTINE PETERSON ON BEHALF
OF IMPACT POWER SOLUTIONS AND
TRANSPORT OF. TWENTY SIXTEEN.
I'M GONNA LINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PRODUCT TRITON ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS THANK YOU. MR HAVE NO
NOTHING TO AT THE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO ASK YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S A TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION- TWO MINUTES MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT. YEAH YES THIS MAP
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK I'VE BEEN
ON THE LINE- WAITING TO SPEAK. I
JUST WANTED TO OFFER OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN WE WORKED. WITH THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR ON THE
LEGISLATION AND WE THINK THAT
THREAT CYNICAL ON THAT IF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN USED BY
VARIOUS PARTIES THANK YOU FOR.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I GOOD AFTERNOON
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC- WE STOP IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE BILL I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR A PRETTY THOROUGH ANALYSIS I
THINK SUMMARIZE THE IT IS AND
COMPLEXITIES WITH PROGRAM AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS- WE- DUSK.
POTENTIAL OUR SEVERAL OP PROGRAM
GUARDRAILS THAT I THINK NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED GOING FORWARD- WE
HAVE REALLY APPRECIATED THE
COMMITTEES FOCUS OF THE LAST
YEAR ON AFFORDABILITY ON RATES-
WE DO THINK THAT THE BILL KIND
OF TAKES A STEP IN THE WRONG IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION IT WITHIN
AND CARD I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
GOODNESS SO. THIS IS BRANDY
REQUISITE GAS ELECTRIC GENERALLY
ECHO ALL THE COMMENTS FROM
ISRAEL'S SEPARATE SENIOR GAS
ELECTRIC OUT NOT REALLY MUCH
ELSE WE CAN ADD BESIDES
HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT THAT-
ADMISSION ANALYSIS THERE ARE
EFFECTIVELY FOUR FIVE AND I WANT
TO FIND OF EXISTING COMMUNITY
SOLAR PROGRAMS. HAVE HAD
MARGINAL OR SUCCESS AT ALL FOR
VARIOUS MARKET REASONS THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO KIND OF
RECREATE THE WHEEL THERE IS
ONGOING PROCEEDINGS AT THE PC-
AT SOMETIME IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THAT THESE HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
FORUMS WE THINK THAT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE IT.
SO WE'LL ASK UP THE MODERATOR TO
SEE IF- ANYONE IS CALLING IN TO
STATE THEIR OPPOSITION FOR THE
BILL. I WANT. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THISTIME.
JERRY HAVE NOTING TO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ALAS FOLKS IN
THE ROOM IF THEY WANNA STEP
FORWARD NAME ORGANIZATION. THANK
YOU KIM STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
OUR POSITION. UNLESS AMENDED.
THE COMMUNITY SOLAR FANS OF THE
SPONSORS FANS OF THE AUTHOR BUT
HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND WITH THE
SPONSORS HAVE A COUPLE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WITH- ABOUT THE BILL
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS. THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IS A MEMBER
JERRY MEMBERS- IN BECAUSE THERE
WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
S. C. IS OPPOSED TO REPAIR FUNDS
BEING USED TO SUBSIDIZE AN
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. K. WILL BRING IT
BACK TO BY THE DICE ANY
QUESTIONS. OF THE OTHER. FOR THE
AUTHOR YES DOCTOR. SO I WOULD
PREFER THAT THIS REMAIN WITH THE
P. C. P. U. C. BOB. IF YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS HERE- I HAD
A HARD TIME FOLLOWING. ALL
GRAMPS THURSDAY G. A. C. G. G.
C. S. CHU CHI. R. G. T. E. C. R.
IT CETERA- IT'S VERY HARD I
THINK FOR US AS LEGISLATORS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW ALL OF
THESE WORK TOGETHER AND TO SEE
WHAT THIS BILLS OF THE CPUC
ALREADY- WAS ASKED TO LOOK AT
TWICE NOW TO LOOK AT A SIMILAR
PROGRAM. THEY BASICALLY SAID. WE
HOPE HELLO ENOUGH RIGHT NOW TO
DO SOMETHING WE NEED MORE TIME-
IN IT CAN. BOTH THE CONSULTANT
AND FRANKLY THE ANALYSIS SAYS
THAT THERE IS LIKELY TO BE A
COST SHIFT- WHAT'S THE OTHER
CONCERN KASHIF- ONE MORE. AREA.
I GUESS THAT'S ENOUGH- THE- THE
OTHER THING IS WE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE NO TROUBLE AT ALL BUILDING
ALL THE SOLAR WE MEET- BECAUSE
WE ALREADY HAVE THE MANDATE.
UTILITIES CAN BE. YOU KNOW THEY
CAN PUT IN FORM THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS MIL MAYBE EVEN A
MILLION HOMES WITH JUST ONE FARM
. SO I DON'T THINK THEY NEED IN
TERMS OF REACHING OUR GOALS. I
THINK THIS IS TOO COMPLICATED
FOR ME ANYWAY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON. THE CPUC HAS
SAID THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO UNDERSTAND THAT
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T. I WOULD
PREFERRED THAT THERE SIMPLY GOT
ONE. THANK YOU. DR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR I THINK ANY TIME WE
TRY TO. YOU KNOW HAVE A- SOME
KIND OF CONVERSATION REGARDING
ANYTHING THE CPC DOES THAT'S
OFTENTIMES- JUST FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD IT JUST IT TAKES A
LONG TIME FOR THE PC TO ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING. AND I DON'T MEAN
TO BE DISRESPECTFUL TO THE P. C.
R. TO THE FOLKS THERE BUT WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH THE ISSUE
OF THE KASHIF RELATED TO NOT A
JIMMY DURING FOR QUITE SOME TIME
IN FACT THE PC HAS MANDATED. TO
THERE IS NOW IN THE- A NEW
LEADERSHIP AT THE P. YOU SEE ADS
WE HEAR FROM. EXCUSES LIKE I'M
NEW AND I NEED TO CATCH UP AND I
NEED TO DO THIS EVEN THOUGH
STAFF HAS BEEN THERE FOR MANY
YEARS AND SO I JUST YOU KNOW I
WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INTENT OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
CREATE BUT- BASED EVEN ON THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT GOES
FURTHER THAN THE BILL THAT I
CURRENTLY HAVE ON TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE FORTY THREE RELATED TO NAM
AND PREVAILING WAGE. AND I'M I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED OF ADDING
ADDITIONAL. UP WORK TO THE P.
YOU SEE WHEN THEY HAVE YET TO DO
THE WORK THAT THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE AND SO I WILL BE VOTING IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
HOPE THAT AS THE RECISIONS FULL
WHAT WE CAN BUY SOME CONCERNS
THAT BASED. I'M PERSONALLY
RELATES DOLLAR PREVAILING WAGE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
ADDRESSING THE CAUTION- AND THEN
REALLY ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
HOW DO WE CREATE. A CLEAN GREEN
ECONOMY WITH THE WORK FORCE THAT
IS. EARNING THAT SAME WAY H. AS
IN THE REDUCTION OF FOSSIL FUEL
SO ALL OF THAT IS COMBINED. AND
THESE ARE THINGS THAT YOU AND I.
UP BUT AGAIN MY CONCERN IS JUST
SIMPLY CREATING ADDITIONAL
THINGS FOR THE P. YOU SEE TO DO
WHEN THEY'VE YET TO ACTUALLY DO
THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY MANDATEDTO DO. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY THE NOT DIRECT TO
A DRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE COMMITTEES DEEP ANALYSIS ON
THIS AND AGAIN MINDFUL THAT-
WITH THAT SOMETHING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE REALLY WORKING SOME OF THE
IMMIGRATION DETAILS THROUGH THE
PVC. PIPE SHARE. SUMMARY OF THE
ISSUE OF THE PC AND THEIR
ACTIONS AND I'M SURE THERE ARE
REASONS WHY THEY TAKE AS LONG AS
THEY DO- BUT TO THE EXTENT OF
THEIR THE ISSUE WE BELIEVE WITH
THE- SPONSORS AND THOSE THAT
WERE WORKING WITH ON THE BILL.
THAT ON THE COSTS OF USE WILL
BE. NEGLIGIBLE AT BEST AND
HOPEFULLY WILL NOT BE THERE AT
ALL GIVEN BOTH THE- DESIGN OF
THE PROGRAM THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO- AUTHORIZE HERE. AS WELL.
WHAT WE OTHER CANNOT. WHEN THEY
WORK ON IT WITH REGARD TO ANY M.
THREE POINT NO THIS IS ALL LINE
YOU KNOW THROUGH A PART OF THAT
WORK TO- WORK IN PROGRESS AND I
KNOW THE DETAILS OF NOT BEEN
FINALIZED RIGHT NOW BUT I
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO FOR US
TO MOVE FORWARD. SO THAT WE CAN
GIVE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ROOFTOP SOLAR THOSE THAT NEED
THIS ALTERNATIVE- AUTHORIZATION
AND ESPECIALLY WITH A LOT OF
FEDERAL SUPPORT THAT WE KNOW IS
COMING DOWN HERE. THAT WE HOPE
WILL BE- AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
POTENTIAL CONSUMERS IN YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I THINK IT
WILL HELP US MEET OUR GOALS EVEN
FASTER. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEES AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
YOU. MANY TO. THE CONVERSATION
CLOSER TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED AND SO- WITH THAT AWESOME
SECRETARY'S REMOTE WE HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE. MOTIONS ARE SECOND.
SECOND STRONG ROCCA. ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO CARILLO. CARILLO I
CHEN. CHEN NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM
. CUNNINGHAM NO FONG. FONG I
CRISTINA GARCIA GIPSON. GIPSON I
HOLDEN MAYES MURATSUCHI QUIRK
NOW PORTANTINO REYES REYES ICE
SANTIAGO KING. THAT'S FIVE THREE
OKAY WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MEMBER SAID ON. THE
OTHER MEMBERS. WE TAKE- AN
ACTION OR EMOTION FIRST AND THE
SECOND FOR THE CONSECUTIVE JOB
OF CONSENT. TO MOTIONS SECOND.
THEY GIVE. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. RECOMMENDED
CONSENT EDUARDO GARCIA HI IN
ORDER C. I. PATTERSON. PATTERSON
I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CHAN AYE
CHAN AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. FONG. FONG I CRISTINA GARCIA
GIPSON GIPSON HI HOLDEN MAYES
MURATSUCHI QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES. SANTIAGO KING. THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THAT THE BILL WE
DO HAVE A BILL THAT WAS
PRESENTED ON THAT WAS BUILT
TWENTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT BY MR
CHOI YOUR ROUND DAYLIGHT SAVING
TIME IS OUR MOTION- TO MOVE THAT
BILL FORWARD. MOTIONS THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI IN ORDER GARCIA AYE PATTERSON
PATTERSON NO CARILLO. CREO NOT
VOTING CHEN CHEN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG FONG HI
CRISTINA GARCIA GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE HOLDEN MAYES MURATSUCHI
QUIRK NOW QUICK NO REYES.
SANTIAGO KING. THAT'S FIVE TWO
THANK YOU LOU THE ROLE FOR THAT-
BILLS WELL WE HAVE TWO OTHER
PRESENTERS I- VOLUNTEERED TO
PRESENT- A BILL FOR ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE SO OF THEIR PAST
THE GAVEL DOWN IF SERGEANTS IF
YOU CAN CALL THE REMAINING-
OTHERS THAT- MR MURATSUCHI AND-
MISTER KING.
RIGHT TWENTY EIGHTY THREE HER
HIS RIGHT SURE COLLEAGUES WHO MY
KIND GENEROSITY AGREED TO.
RESENT THIS BILL FOR OUR
COLLEAGUE REBECCA BARKAT ON
BEHALF OFASSEMBLY MEMBER- TODAY
PRESENTS YOU AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE A BILL THAT PROTECTS YOU
TO THE REPAIRS IN SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS FOR UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ABLE. WE DO HAVE WE DO HAVE
. CAN I HAVE A PRIMARY TESTIFIED
WE DO SUPPORT. STUDENTS SAY WHO. PHONE. THIS IS KATIE MARCONI
FROM TURN I'M I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT. A TESTIFYING AS WELL L.
A. RIVER IN SUPPORT. I CAN'T.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO ON NOW.
IS THIS ONE OF THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT. YES HI MY NAME IS KATIE
MARCONI AND I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY RETURN THEUTILITY
REFORM NETWORK. TURN IS A PROUD
SPONSOR THIS BILL PROTECTING
RATEPAYERS FROM FUNDING REMEDY
THAT UTILITY AGREES TO
ENTITLEMENT IN ORDER TO AVOID
PROSECUTION. BUT OFFICE BILL
UTILITIES BABY CAVALIER ENOUGH
TO TRY AND SHIFTING COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS DOING SO DEFEATS THE
PURPOSES OF HOLDING THE UTILITY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MISMANAGEMENT AND SALES
OPERATIONS OF ITS FACILITIES.
THE EIGHTY THREE PLACE. AND THE
WRONG TO OUR AND DOES ALLOW TO
TAKE ON A UNMARKED COST. PG&E
HAS EXITED A FIVE YEAR PROBATION
FOR CRIMINAL CONDUCT STEMMING
FROM THE TWENTY TEN SAN BRUNO
INCIDENT THE CORPORATION IS A
FELON AND HAS EVERY INCENTIVE TO
AVOID ADDITIONAL CRIMINAL
CHARGES. PG&E ENTERED INTO A
SETTLEMENT. OTHER CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES TO AVOID ADDITIONAL
CRIMINAL CHARGES RELATED TO THE
DIXIE FIRE- IT INCLUDES DIRECT
PAYMENT THE MONETARY RELIEF AND
OTHER REMEDIES INCLUDING NEW
POSITIONS AND WATER STATIONS BUT
THESE OTHER AMITY SO HOW COST
AND IT SHOULD BE PAID BY
SHAREHOLDERS. THE LANGUAGE OF
THE AGREEMENT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT CERTAIN COSTS CANNOT BE
PASSED ALONG TO RATEPAYERS BUT
IT IS NOT CLEAR ON OTHERS
SHIFTING ANY COSTS FOR PREMATURE
WHAT PROSECUTION SHOULD NEVER BE
AN OPTION ARE LIKE TO I THINK.
AS B. EIGHTY. CAN'T THAT
REPAIRED MAY PAY A COUPLE FOR
THE UTILITIES MANAGE. IF I
INVESTOR REPORTING HIGHLIGHT
CERTAIN RUN LIKE THE NEW TO WILL
BE PAID FOR YOU RATES THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL WOULD
PREVENT THAT FROM EVEN BEING AN
OPTION. THE BILL AND HOLDEN
UTILITY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ITS MISDEEDS IN
PROTECTORATE PAYER TO ALREADY
PAID DEARLY FOR THE ELECTRIC
SERVICE FROM PAYING EVEN MORE
FOR THE OPERATIONAL FAILURE OF
UTILITY. TURN IT GREAT BELIEVES
THAT SPEAK OUT OF THE IF A
COMPUTER COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY
THE UTILITY BECAUSE LIFE THERE
IS WELL DESERVED BUT THAT
RESTITUTION SHOULD NOT BE
FOLLOWED. FUNDED BY FELLOW
UTILITY RATEPAYERS ANY ACTION
PROMISED TO BE UNDERTAKEN IN
EXCHANGE FOR AVOIDING THE
PROSECUTION SHOULD BE PAID FOR
BY THE UTILITY. NATALIE CASE
AVOID FURTHER CHARGES RT VALUE
TO SHAREHOLDERS AND THE FATHER
INSURE THAT THE UTILITY COULD
NOT FURTHER ENRICH THEIR SAME
CHILD HOLDERS. BY ALLOWING
RATEPAYERS TO PAY FOR
SETTLEMENTS EVEN IN PART. OF THE
PROBLEM OUT THERE THE START
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU TO THAT
I. MEMBERS RIGHT CHOI RIGHT I DO
HAVE- NOTE HERE THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER PERSON THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING YEAH WE NOTICED THAT
EMILY BROWN THE STATE WORKER
YANKING OUT MISSED MODERATOR.
YES BOB THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SHOWS ARE STILL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS WILLIE
BROWN'S AND I GAVE EACH ACROSS
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURTS. AS WELL
AS REGULATORY PROCEEDINGS ON
RELATED UTILITY WHILE
PARKINSON'S. EXPERIENCES I
UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
AB TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT. TO
ENSURE UTILITIES DON'T CONTINUE
TO NEGOTIATE AWAY PUBLIC SAFETY.
CORPORATE BUILDING. AND WILDFIRE
MITIGATION RESPONSIBILITIES. YES
SETTLEMENT SYMBOL INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES LIKE PG&E. TO MAKE
THEIR CORPORATE MALFEASANCE
BECOME OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
ABILITIES. HERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES. THANK YOU FOR THE MEAL
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED FAR SETTLEMENT BE
COUNTY. AS A HARBINGER TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE.
IN SEVENTY ON JUST YOU THOUGHT
SO. THIS PUBLISHED HELPS YOU
FORGET BEFORE JOE POLITICS. FOR
PERSONAL INJURY STARTED WORKING
TO SETTLE UNDER. AMOUNT AND
BILLIONS. BOB ARE THE MOST
RECENT DATA THAT PEOPLE
SETTLEMENTS JUST CERTAIN AMOUNTS
A FEW WEEKS AGO. ONLY WHICH
SPOKE OUR BEFORE JUDGE ALSO HE
STATED HERE'S HOW THIS IS GOING
TO PLAY OUT. HE JENNY WILL TAKE
OF DOLLARS THESE CAN. AND WALK
AWAY YOU CAN GET THE KERR. THE
COUNTIES WHAT WE S. HOLD THE
DA'S ACCOUNTABLE TO PUTTING THIS
COMPANY I'M CONTINUE PROBATION.
I TOOK THIS DIRECTION BUDGET
ALSIP THE CINEMA COUNTY COOPER.
DID ONE HOSTILE WHAT WHILE PER
OCCURRING THE- WHY THE AG
STEPPING IN. WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND GIACOMIN. GIVE US BETTER
TOOLS TO DEAL WITH THESE TYPES
OF CORPORATE CRIMINALS. YES YOU
DO NEED SETTLED LARGE MARIN
SONOMA COUNTY HISTORY. FOR THE
CORPORATE EQUIVALENT OF A
PARKING TICKET AND WAS REWARDED
WITH THE STAFF ON ABOUT SOME
REPAIRS. THE SETTLEMENTS ALL
MADE PHD INTERVIEWED LIKE TRY
AND I. ASSAULTS VALUE ATG REASON
. UNDER AB TWENTY FOUR WHILE
THEY ARE FOUND RIGHT IN CRIMINAL
AS PART SEVERAL. THESE
REASONABLE YET CRIMINAL
CONTRADICTIONS ARE UNTENABLE I
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND AGAIN MY VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE I'M HOPING IT'S ONLY
QUESTIONS. ABOUT MY ENGAGEMENT
IN THESE CASES. THANK. GO TO- IN
THE ROOM FOR OTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION OKAY LET'S DO THIS TO
OPPOSITION WITH DISPENSED WITH
THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING THAT HONEST
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC AND SOCALGAS I'M
HERE IN OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK WE BELIEVE THIS BILL-
CIRCUMVENTS THE CPC'S EXCLUSIVE
FORTY TO REVIEW- COSTS AND
IMPROVE EXPENSES- THAT ARE JUST
AND REASONABLE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT AT THIRTY SHOULD
MAINTAIN A BE MAINTAINED. YOU
SEE A COUPLE OF THE THAT WE HAVE
IS THEM. WE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENCES IT IT
THIS BILL WOULD INTERFERE WITH-
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT I'M TO
EXTENT TELL ME. BY THAT. I
IMPROVE TO- THE SYSTEM INCREASED
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE. OR
OTHER RELATED COSTS THAT ARE
HAVE TO DO WITH ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- AS- AS BILLS
DRAFTED IT WOULD APPLY TO WORKS
IN PROGRESS AND ALREADY PLANNED
TO- WORKS IN PROGRESS OUT WIND
LIQUIDATION BEGINS AND WE FEEL
LIKE THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE BY
EXTENSION. THE BILL ALSO WOULD
UNDERMINE AT THE WILDFIRE FUND
DEAL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE
UNDERSTAND THE MEMBERS TRY TO
CLARIFY THAT- WE WOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO SEEK RECOVERY WHEN
PROSECUTED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DA'S- COUNTY CITY
ATTORNEY'S ECCENTRIC BUT-
EXPANDS THE BILL TO ALSO INCLUDE
CIVIL PROSECUTIONS. ON THAT
PARTICULAR REFERENCE MORE
PAYMENT UNDERMINE THE AB TEND TO
DO FOR FRAMEWORK IT CHANGES THE
TERMS OF THAT PARTICULAR ON
LEGISLATIVE DEAL AND OUT AT THAT
TIME WE RELIED. ON THAT
PARTICULAR NEGOTIATION WHEN WE
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
WILDFIRE FINE- SO. THAT BEING
CHANGED THAT WE FEEL LIKE- IT
WOULD IT WOULD. SKEWS ME SO THAT
PARTICULAR REMARK AT THAT TIME-
ALLOWED AS EACH NEED TO THE
RIGHT TO SEEK RECOVERY FOR
SETTLEMENT AMOUNTS PAID TO
RESOLVE WILDFIRE RELATED CLAIMS-
AND THAT A BILL ALSO ESTABLISHED
A PRESUMPTION IN FAVOUR OF
RATEPAYER FUNDED RECOVERY FOR
THOSE AMOUNTS IF ELECTORAL
CORPORATIONS- HOLD A VALID A
VALID STATE IT DIFFICULT SO THE
DIFFERENCE BEING THAT. THERE ARE
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS ON THE ONE
HAND AND THERE ARE ALL THESE
LINES ON THE OTHER HAND WE FEEL
LIKE THIS KIND OF. THAT'S
MENTIONED THE ADDITIONAL AGAIN
OF ADDING CIVIL PROSECUTION
WHICH WE BELIEVE INTERFERES WITH
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR DEAL SET TO
CONCLUDE- JUST GENERALLY
SPEAKING WE- THE US WEAPONS HE-
THE WRONG IN THESE PARTICULAR
DECISIONS THEY'RE NOT APPROVING
CRIMINAL FINES OR PENALTIES FOR
RECOVERY FROM RATEPAYERS- SO
WE'RE UNSURE WHY. INTO A- THEM
AT THE- FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
CASES WERE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR I'M TO
ADDRESS HIS CONCERNS ABOUT
STEVEN WROTE DOWN TO
DISCRIMINATE PROSECUTION BUT-
FOR TODAY AND FOR US. AS A TODAY
AND RESPECT WHAT POSITION WOULD
PRESENT ABOUT THANK YOU. YEAH
ADAM SMITH SO THERE ARE SOME
ALSO OPPOSING I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC SAID IT VERY WELL SO I
WON'T RETREAD THE SAME GROUND
ADELINE MY COMMENTS. BUT WITH
HERS ON THE REAL POINT OF THE
MATTER LET THE PC WE THINK HAS
COMPLETE DISCRETION OVER THESE.
REASONABLE COST WHETHER THE
REASON OR NOT ALREADY NOT SURE
WHAT THIS BILL IS KIND OF ADDING
TO THAT EXPLICITLY. BUT I'D ALSO
SAY I THINK ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE'VE WHEN WE WERE TRYING
TO. ASSESS THE LANGUAGE AND HOW
IT WOULD IMPACT WHAT WE'RE
ALREADY DOING ON WILDFIRE IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEARANCES. WANT TO
KEEP TALKING THE AUTHORS. ABOUT
AND WE URGE YOU TO- CONSIDER AS
WELL THERE ARE OFTEN TIMES WHERE
IN AIDS YOU KNOW MAYBE A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WE MIGHT
EVEN. COMMIT TO THINGS IN AGREE
TO THINGS LIKE. YOU KNOW KIND OF
RAMPING UP CONTRACTOR
ENFORCEMENT AND MANAGEMENT ND
OVERSIGHT. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WHILE IT'S PART OF A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. LIKE HECK
. YOU KNOW BERMAN AGREEMENT HAS
RAISED OTHER ISSUES OR OTHER
INTERESTS ACROSS OUR BROADER
SERVICE TERRITORY AND INSTEAD OF
KIND OF JUST NEARLY FOCUSING YOU
KNOW ON THE CONTRACTOR OVERSIGHT
IN A SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHIC REGION
WE MIGHT RAMP UP CONTRACTOR
OVERSIGHT ACROSS OUR ENTIRE
SERVICE TERRITORY THIS BILL AND
THE LANGUAGE BUT SENATE RIGHT.
TO MAKE IT CLEAR IT THE RAMP UP.
SITE BECAUSE WE REALIZE HEY THAT
WAS A PROBLEM THERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO FIX DOESN'T MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY GO
TO SECRET RECOVERY FOR THOSE
ACTIVITIES IS WHEN THEY FALL
UNDER THE BILL. CAN BE SOMETHING
THAT WILL KIND OF PSEUDO PART OF
THE SETTLEMENT WOULD BE
SOMETHING WE COULD ACTUALLY GO
TO THE PC TO DISCUSS AND SEE IF
THE BROAD BASED. YOU KNOW HOW.
THE FITTING THE BROADER RATE
BASE AND THAT'S WHAT WE LIKE TO
JUST KIND OF PRESERVE HERE IS
THE PUC'S ABILITY TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
WHAT ARE JUST AND REASONABLE
COSTS AND WE THINK THAT THE BILL
AS IT SITS TODAY BLURS THOSE
LINES RESPECTFULLY BUT- A NO
VOTE. HI SIR BRING YOU BACK WITH
SPECIFIC GUEST LECTURED WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR- OUR CONCERNS
WITH IT AT A SAN ANTONIO WE HAVE
NOT TAKEN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
AMENDED. EIGHT DAYS AGO- BUT
WOULD YOU HAVE IF YOU TURN AT
THAT GIVEN HOW BROAD IT IS GIVEN
IT WAS MENTIONED- BY THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE HAVE ZERO INTENTION
OF RECOVERING ANY OF THE RECENT
SILENCE FROM CUSTOMERS. ARE
CONCERNS ARE RELATED TO HELP. GO
FOR THE- WITH REGARD TO TYPICAL-
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ISSUES SO
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY POST NEXT.
AND MOVED FROM MODERATOR WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT NEXT RIGHT. YEAH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE A- TO PUBLIC.
COMMENTS IS THIS ON THE PHONE OR
NOT. SO ON THE PHONE. WE'RE
GONNA DO THIS AHEAD OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE HERE. OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO A PUBLIC COMMENT- IS
THIS IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION
OF BOTH ALL ALL RIGHT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE PLEASE. THE ONLY PRIVILEGE SPEAK ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST NOW WE
DO HAVE. ONE COMING UP.
MISTER CHAIR WILL GO WITH ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM ACTUALLY CALLING
IN ON A PREVIOUS- BILL. THE
PHONES ARE DOWN AB TWO EIGHT SIX
EIGHT THAT THE PERMANENT
DAYLIGHT SAVING. I DO WANT TO
RAISE AN OBJECTION BECAUSE AFTER
THE COMMITTEE WOULD NOT PRESENT
FELT SORRY THAT THAT BILL'S BEEN
HEARD IN VOTED ON. I'M SORRY
THAT THE- YOUR YOU'RE TOO LATE
SIR. SORRY BROWN TWENTY. TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. YEAH I
WE'RE GONNA GO NEXT TO WELL
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
A SUPPORT AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OR IN BETWEEN I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN AB TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE OF SO PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
SEE THAT WOULD. YEAH. I'M GONNA
MOVE TO MEMBERS ANY- QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS MEMBERS BUT QUICK ARE
YES SO THIS IS MY CONCERN- FIRST
OF ALL IN THE SETTLEMENT WHOEVER
IS SUING COULD JUST SAY UNDER
THESE TERMS- YOU CANNOT ASK FOR
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE C. P. U.
C. THAT CAN BE PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT. SECOND AS WAS
POINTED OUT THE CPUC IS IN GOOD
POSITION TO DECIDE. WHAT IF FIVE
IF IN THE SETTLEMENT. THEY DON'T
DECIDE TO DO THAT THEN THE CPUC
COULD DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE BUT THEY ALL THEY
ALWAYS HAVE THAT OPTION OF JUST
MAKING. THAT PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT THE THIRD CONCERN I
HAVE IS THAT IN EFFECT THIS
LIMITS WHAT YOU CAN SUE FOR. AND
HERE'S WHAT I'M ME IF THE H. G.
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL GETS
INVOLVED BECAUSE IT'S MULTIPLE
SMALL COUNTY SAY AROUND TRINITY
WHERE THE COUNTIES ARE SO SMALL.
AND THEY REALLY CAN'T BRING THE
SUIT. IT REALLY LIMITS WHAT THAT
THE AG COULD DO THE AG FOR
EXAMPLE MIGHT WANT TO SAY
ALRIGHT SYSTEM WIDE. G. IN AB
THAT'S HAS ALL THESE SMALL
COUNTIES THAT- YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO X. Y. AND Z. HERE.
AND THAT COULD END UP BAY
UNDERGROUND LINES WHATEVER A
HUGE COST. SOMETHING THAT MIGHT
SEND THE COMPANY INTO BANKRUPTCY
WHICH WE DO NOT WANT TO DO SO
THE AGE SHE CAN'T ASK FOR THAT
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE IS
BANKRUPTCY FOR THE COMPANY. AND
THAT'S WE'VE LEARNED THAT'S NOT
SMART. SO THIS IN EFFECT WHAT
THE STATE BILL IS DOING IS
LIMITING WHAT YOU CAN SUE FOR
AND FOR THAT REASON I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT. ANY OTHER MEMBERS. MISTER SEA WATER WORK CLOTHES
AND ASK IF YOU'RE GOING TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YEAH SHE SHE GREW TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS ALL. RIGHT
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WILL. IS HERE A MOTION OR A
SECOND AND A SECOND ON A B. TWO
ZERO EIGHT THREE. HELLO GIPSON
EMOTIONS WHICH MOVIES ARE SECOND
. YEAH I HAVE GIPSON NUMBER CG
OKAY. HI I'M NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA HI
IN ORDER C. I. PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING CARILLO HER
CARILLO AYE CHAN. CHENNAI VOTING
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
FONG. FONG I CRISTINA GARCIA
GIPSON- GIPSON HI HOLDEN MAYES
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE CORK
NOW QUICK NO REYES. REYES AYE
SANTIAGO KING. SIX ONE KEEP THAT
BILL. SECOND CALL- SO YOU KNOW
WE KEEP TRACK OF THAT THAT'S SIX
ONE WILL I KEEP IT ON CALL FOR
OTHER MEMBERS.
SOME MEMBERS TO CHEER UP TO
BILLS. PICTURE WHEN YOU WANT TO
GO FIRST. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I THINK A- THE ONCE THROUGH
COOLING PLANT IS. FIRST ON THE
AGENDA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS BUT SHARE AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE- I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWO ONE FOUR ZERO. WHICH
SEEKS TO. STOP DELAYING THE
SHUTTING DOWN OF THE ONCE
THROUGH COOLING NATURAL GAS
POWER PLANTS THAT- WAS
ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED FOR THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY. I WAS EXTENDED
ONCE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
WAS A- EXTENDED AGAIN- IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR SB ONE HUNDRED GOALS
OF TRANSITIONING 21100% CLEAN
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WE NEED TO HAVE OUR
DEADLINES MATTER. THIS DEADLINE
TO PHASE OUT HE WANTS TO COOLING
POWER PLANTS BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY WAS ADOPTED IN
TWENTY TEN. WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO
APPROACH THIS IN A RESPONSIBLE
MANNER AND APPRECIATE THE- THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT TO THAT THE SHUTTING DOWN
OF ANY ONCE THE COOLING PLANTS-
DO NOT UNDERMINE. EITHER
STATEWIDE OR LOCAL ELECTRICITY I
BUILDING. BY REQUIRING AS A
CONDITION OF NO FURTHER
EXTENSION FOR THE- ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH INCLUDES THE P.
YOU SEE THE ENERGY COMMISSION B-
HI SO- AS WELL AS THE WATER
BOARD- TO DETERMINE. AT THE
SHUTTING DOWN OF THE- COASTAL-
ONCE THROUGH COOLING PLANT WOULD
NOT JEOPARDIZE- ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY. AND I WANT TO ADD
THAT TO JUST RECENTLY- IN MARCH
OF THIS YEAR THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ISSUED A REPORT THAT
CONCLUDED AS STATED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES- THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT. FORESEE OUR
RECOMMEND ANY CHANGES TO THE
COMPLIANCE SCHEDULED THUS FAR
AND SO YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THE PC IS
TESTIFIED- PRESIDENT REYNOLDS
TESTIFIED THAT THEY HAVE- ISSUED
THE ORDERS FOR PROCUREMENT FOR-
ADEQUATE ENERGY TO- ALLOW FOR
THE SHUTTING DOWN ONCE AND FOR
ALL OF THESE CALLS SO- ONCE
THROUGH COOLING PLANTS- AND SO
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO- TO SUPPORTING WITNESSES
FOR THE SPELL- THE MAYOR OF
REDONDO BEACH BILL BRAND HAS
BEEN FIGHTING THIS BECAUSE-
SINCE. TWENTY TEN CLOSE SHOT UP
TWELVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER LINES.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BILL GRAN. ON THE
BEACH FOR FIVE YEARS AND WITH
THE COUNCIL MEMBER IN THIS
DISTRICT WITH EIGHT YEARS PRIOR
. WHAT FIRST INVOLVED COMING ON
THESE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
REGULATIONS WAY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. USED TO BE A
CHEMICAL ENGINEER SOME VERY
COMFORTABLE DISCUSSING IS VERY
TECHNOLOGY. I WAS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION
LOCAL FIVE OH TWO LA ACTS. THE
ONE YEARS. AT A LARGE POWER
PLANT OWNER COACH IN REDONDO
BEACH FOR OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY YEARS BELIEVE IT OR NOT
THIS PARTICULAR PLAN IS NOW
ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS OLD
NINETEEN POWER PLANTS WERE CITED
ON THE COAST CALIFORNIA IN THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY THE USE OF
OCEAN WATER TO COOL FOR
OPERATIONS OF THE TREMENDOUS
DAMAGE. MARINE ENVIRONMENT EVERY
LIVING ORGANISM THAT IS TUCKED
INTO THE MASSIVE INTAKES DICE.
BUILDING BLOCKS OF OUR LOCAL
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS OUR STATE
WATER BOARD PASSEDWHAT IS KNOWN
AS WHAT YOU'RE CALLING
REGULATIONS WAY BACK IN TWENTY
TEN TO PHASE OUT THE USE OF
OCEAN WATER TO COOL THEIR PLANTS
AND THEY WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
STATE ENERGY AGENCIES A POWER
COMPANY TO ESTABLISH THE STATE'S
WITH THAT WOULD BE THE RETOOL
OUR PERMANENT RETIRE. THE
STATE'S FIRST CAMPUS TWELVE
YEARS AGO THE DATE FOR EXTENDED
FOR FOUR POWER PLANTS BY THREE
YEARS AT THE POWER SHORTAGE BACK
IN TWENTY TWENTY IT BEEN
ADDRESSED. BUT NO ONE CURRENTLY
SERVES THE WATER BOARD WAS
AROUND WHEN THESE REGULATIONS
WERE CRAFTED AMPS. WE CAN YOU DO
THE DEADLINE SET COMPANIES A
RENOWNED BEACH. FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS YEAR. JUST TO BE ON THE
READY REGARDLESS OF WHETHER.
THEY'RE CALLED. POPPERS THE
EXTENSION THE CITY RECENTLY LOST
OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE GRANTS FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND THE CALL TO
CONFIRM TO RESTORE THE WEAPON
HERE AND CREATE PUBLIC OPEN
SPACE PROJECT. IN THE MOST
DENSELY POPULATED AREA THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA COAST. IS A
LONG ESTABLISHED RETIREMENT DATE
HALF IT MEANS SOMETHING AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO KEEP SAID AND
IT'S CLEAR TO ME AFTER ATTENDING
EVERY HERE. ONLY ACTUALLY. TO
PREVENT THE BRANCH FROM COULD
YOU TO OPT. LEGISLATION WEALTHY
OUT LOUD BECAUSE POWER PLAY YOU
CAN OP IF HE AGENCIES LIKE TIGHT
SO. IN THE PAC AND THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. EIGHT TWENTY ONE
TODAY THE ENERGY AGENCY THEN
POWER COMPANIES WILL MEET THE
CHALLENGE BUT ONLY IF YOU PUT A
STOP TO THE IDEA OF SIMPLY
STANDING THE OPERATION OF
SEVENTY YEAR OLD PLANTS THANK
YOU. CAN IN CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME SEAN BOTTLE IN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEP
RELIANCE. ON OUR ORGANIZATION IS
ONE OF THE PRIMARY A GROUPS THAT
ADVOCATED FOR NEGOTIATED THE
ONCE THE COOLING POLICY OVER A
DECADE FROM BASICALLY TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND TEN-
THEN. IN INVOLVED. PROBABLY ONE
OF THE SOLE PRIMARY PEOPLE OF
WORKING ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ONCE YOU. DANCE TO THAT TEN I'M
OVERLAP WILL YEARS. THE INTENSE
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE WANT
TO GO INTO. WILL PROTECT GREEN
LIGHT FROM WANTS TO. WELL SURE
IT WOULD RELY BILL. IN THE END
IN THE CALL BY. A INTO THOUSAND
TEN WE- THAT POWER PLANTS PHASE
OUT WANTS TO. BUT WE DO WE PUT
IN THAT MEASURE TO AND- GRID
RELIABILITY FIRST- WE CREATED A
COMPLIANCE SCHEDULE THAT WAS
STAGGERED NOT EVERYONE HAD A
COMPLY RIGHT AWAY SOME POWER
PLANTS DID. SOME POWER SUCH.
CONTENT WELL THE SEVEN PHASED ON
FOR THE LAST TWELVE YEARS AND BE
CAN TILL TWENTY TWENTY NINE- AND
THAT WAS TO ENSURE THAT WE
WEREN'T LOSING ANY GRID
RELIABILITY AS WE FACE THESE
OUT. AND THEN SECOND ADJUSTMENTS
TO POINTS DIDN'T TO BE MADE.
THAT WAS MADE THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS ADVISORY
GROUP SECUESTRO WHICH IS
COMPRISED. THE ENERGY. AGENCY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
GROUP MEETS EVERY YEAR GIVES A
CONDITION THAT WATER FOR EVERY
YEAR ON GRID RELIABILITY AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH A COMPLAINT
AT ALL. THIS TWENTY ONE FORTY UP
HOLDS A COMPROMISE THAT. EIGHT
IT RELIES STILL SACK WAS TO THE
DECISION. TO LIABILITY WILL BE
INTERRUPTED OR NOT I WOULDN'T BE
HERE RIGHT NOW IF WE DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL DIDN'T
ALIGN WITH THE INTENT AND THE
COMPROMISE THAT WE NEGOTIATE
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN. SO IF
BY CHANCE FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK YOU FOR
THE PRIMARY WITNESS AN
OPPOSITIONAL COME FORWARD THEN
WE'LL GET THE PHONE LINE RICK GO
CALL PEOPLE IN THE ROOM. THE
MOBILE. THANKS. MISTER CHAIRMAN
A MEMBER SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THANK STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL BECAUSE WE SHOULD
UTILITY EMPLOYEES THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS I WAS ACTUALLY ONE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE WATER BOARD
THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING POLICY
THE OBJECTION WE HAVE HELLO THIS
. ZERO IS THE WORDS MATTER IN
THERE'S JUST A NUMBER OF THINGS
IN THIS AND IN THIS BILL.
THEY'RE FACTUALLY NOT
SUPPORTABLE THE FIRST ONE IN THE
IN THE FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS
IS. THAT THERE WAS THE THIS
DESPITE THE STATE BOARDS
DEADLINE. THERE WERE DEADLINES
THERE WAS A SCHEDULED PUT
FORWARD THE DATE HOPE TO REACH
BUT SPECIFICALLY THE POLICY
STATES NO READ ITTO YOU THE
STATE WATER BOARD RECOGNIZES THE
COMPLIANCE DATES POLICY MAY
REQUIRE AMENDMENTS. BASED ON THE
NEED TO MAINTAIN LIABILITY JUST
THIS PAST YEAR THEY EXTENDED THE
LIFE OF A HANDFUL OF THESE
PLANTS BECAUSE WE NEED THEM TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE TERROR OF FROM THE BY
DIMINISH PATIENT THIS GOING TO
STOP LOCAL THE- Y. J. FOR ALL
THE RENEWABLE PROJECTS THAT WE.
SHE MEANT. THIS IT SHOWS THAT
THERE IS A COMMITMENT MADE
THAT'S SIMPLY JUST THE NARRATIVE
BEING CREATED THAT COULD NOT BE
A SLAVE DECORATION THINGS
LAPSLEY THE BIGGEST CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IS THIS BILL GREAT IT'S
WE WOULD ARGUE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
DELEGATION OF LEGISLATIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE HAVE THE
DECISION MAKING POWER ON WHAT
THE FUTURE OF THE PLAN. I WISH
BE. AS IT. THEY ISSUED A NUMBER
DECLARATION OF IS CAN IS V.
FAMILIAR WITH GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ENERGY
IT FULLY OUT THIS SUMMER WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION. I
THINK VERY SPONSORED BELIEVE
THEY'RE OUT- PROCURING EVERY
NATURAL GAS PEAKER PLANT
AVAILABLE IN THE NORTHERN
HEMISPHERE. AND WHERE ARE THEY
LOCATED WELL OF COURSE THEY WERE
LOCATED NEXT TO LOAD WHICH IS
WHAT INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES
PRIMARILY AND WHERE OUR
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES LOCATED IN
MISTER GIBSON'S DISTRICT THE
BUSINESS CAREER WAS DISTRICT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACES DISTRICT.
SO LET'S PROTECT THIS WEALTHY
COMMUNITY IN REDONDO BEACH WHO
IS INCONVENIENCED BY THE FACT
THAT THERE IS. POWER PLANT THERE
THAT OPERATES FOR FIVE DAYS A
YEAR LET'S KEEP BRING IN THE
PEAKER PLANTS THE REGULAR
OPERATE EVEN MORE THAN THAT AND
THAT ARE DIRTIER THAN THE OUR
PLACE. IN ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS-
YOUR URGENT THIS BILL AND BE
AMENDED OR HELPING COMMITTEE
THANK YOU- JAZZ BUDDY JONES FOR
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
AND- WE REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO REPLACE THESE
PLANTS AS WELL AS THE PEOPLE WHO
OWN THESE PLANTS SO- WE- DOES
NOT. WANT TO COOL. BY THIS IS
ABOUT. UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES
DO THESE BIG PLANS CONTINUE
UPDATE HAVE EXTENSIONS AND I
JUST IF THIS BILL WAS FORWARD I
WONDER YEAH I'M WE WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS. BUT THE KEY KEY ISSUE
THAT THE AND- WHICH IS REFERRED
TO. THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A- A
PROCUREMENT ORDER DONE BY THE P.
YOU SEE TO REPLACE THESE UNITS
AS WELL AS DIABLO CANYON OKAY
DOUBLE CANDY GOES OFF TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AT THE
WANTS TO CALL UNITS ARE TO A
THINK AGO- SCHEDULED TO GO
OFFLINE AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF TIME FOR.
THE THAT SO THAT WAS PROCUREMENT
ORDERS ARE OUT THERE THE PROBLEM
IS BETWEEN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
PROBLEMS CAUSED BY KOBE. KOBE
CHINA SHUT DOWN SALAS YOUR
BATTERIES ARE ON A BOAT RIGHT
NOW YOU'RE OUT OF LUCK HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE OUT THAT HE VALLEY STUFF
WORKS WE SHOULD GET STOP
DEPENDED UPON- IMPORT STUFF. AND
THAT WE TO WHICH SIGNIFICANT
DELAY WITH RESPECT TO-
REPLACEMENT OF THESE THINGS THAT
IN THE OUT YEARS. I DON'T KNOW
GOING TO HAPPEN HOPE IS THAT WE
SELL THROUGH WHICH I THINK A
MISTER MERRETT WHICH BASIC. OF
IT OUT- THE EAGLET REPORT ON
WHAT. THESE BILLS NOT. BUT IF
IT'S IF WE RUN INTO PROBLEMS WE
NEED TO AVOID ANY UNNECESSARY
FRICTION IN TERMS OF HOW
DECISIONS GET MADE SELL A
LEVERAGE OF MINE'S BIGGER THAN
MINE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT THAT IS A CONCERN WE NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT I'M A
- MISSED MODEL WERE IN- ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE HAVE
THE- AND IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ON JAZEERA KNOWING TO AT
THE TIME OKAY WELL UP ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. WE SHOULD COME FORWARD
AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY. OKAY SEE NO ONE. HELLO
BRING BACK TO THAT QUESTION SO
START TO THE FAR RIGHT. MR LEWIS
GOES REYES SO THE WORK ANYWAYS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I HAVE
IS CONCERNS AS NOTED BY BY. THE
SPEAKERS AT AND THESE DO HAVE TO
BE ADDRESSED I- TO SAY THAT IT
THAT'S A DEADLINE- BLAND IT'S A
SCHEDULE AS OPPOSED TO SAYING
THIS IS THE DROP DEAD DATE I
THINK IS IMPORTANT TO THAT'S A
TO NOT- IT. I WILL BE A COURTESY
I'VE TODAY. BUT THE ISSUES MUST
BE ADDRESSED BEFORE GOES TO THE
FLOOR- AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL.
BE MEETING WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO. IF THAT DOES HAPPEN. I HAVE
A COUPLE DIFFERENT COMMENTS THE
NOW SUS NOTES AND THIS IS PRETTY
WELL WELL PUT SO KUDOS TO
WHOEVER. WROTE IT ALL THREE
ASPECTS OF RELIABILITY SYSTEM
LOCAL INFLEXIBLE MUST BE
MAINTAINED IT GOES ON TO SAY
WITH THE CPUC NOTES MOST ENERGY
RESOURCES ARE SCHEDULED TO COME
ONLINE AS PLANNED. AND THUS THE
CURRENT RETIREMENT SCHEDULE IS
UNLIKELY TO CHANGE THE PANDEMIC
EQUIPMENT SHORTAGES JENKINS WORK
FOR OUR FAULTS COULD WE DO A
RESOURCE DELIVERY. THIS BILL MAY
LIMIT STATE AGENCY RESPONSE
SHOULD UNEXPECTED DELAYS OCCUR
NECESSITATE ANOTHER REVIEW OF
THE OTC REQUIREMENTS SO IF I CAN
MAKE MY SECOND POINT AND THEN IF
THE AUTHOR OR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES SUPPORT COULD ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN BECAUSE THAT SEEMS.
FAIRLY WELL FOUNDED I MEAN WERE
ENTERING A POSITION WE'VE GOT
RED AND RELIABILITY TERMS THAT
IS POISED ON A KNIFE'S EDGE TO
BEGIN WITH WE'RE LOSING OF OUR
MAJOR ASSETS IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WITH THE
ABOVE ANYTHING OFF LINE. UP
PERCENT THE STATE'S ENERGY
PRODUCTION. IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
BILL TO ME RESPECTFULLY IS
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF LESS
FLEXIBILITY IN SOME AND MORE.
THE OTHER ISSUE IN THIS IS MORE
HIGHLIGHTED BY MR WET BUT I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON IT COMMONER
FEEDBACK IS. YEAH THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY THIS IS. TO ME
MEAN YOU'VE GOT A- SORT OF PODGE
SORT OF AGENCY THAT'S KIND OF
THIS FRANKENSTEIN CREATION
CALLED. SACK WES ARE SOMETHING
FOR WITH PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER
OTHER AGENCIES. I NOBODY VOTED
FOR IT. A HOUSES IT'S NOT
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE- BUT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THAT THE
ENTITY. THE POWER TO OVERRIDE
THE WATER BOARD WHICH IS
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE-
UNEQUIVOCALLY IF I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE BILL'S DOING CORRECTLY-
AND THAT RAISES OTHER ISSUES
WHERE. YES SOME OF THESE THINGS
WE YOU KNOW WE WANT LOCAL
CONTROL LOCAL INPUT OVER OUR
ENERGY ASSETS TO A DEGREE BUT-
THERE'S A REASON WE HOUSE A LOT
OF THESE DECISIONS TO ME VERY
RATIONALLY. AT THE STATE BECAUSE
THAT LEVELS MAYBE LESS
INFLUENCED BY NIMBY CONCERNS
LESS INFLUENCED BY LOCAL INPUT
AND HAS IT THE ABILITY AND THE
FREEDOM AND LATITUDE TO STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT THE OVERALL
GREAT RISK RELIABILITY- SO
THAT'S THE- BUT THIS BILL IT
EVEN SETTING ASIDE THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY FOR SECOND I
WHICH I DON'T I DON'T GET I
DON'T GET HOW. ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT WAS NEVER AUTHORIZED IN
STATUTE NOW IS GOING TO TAKE
PRIORITY AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OVERRIDE AN AGENCY THAT IS
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE ON A
DECISION RELATING TO WATER. THAT
THAT DOESN'T PENCIL OUT TO ME
SO. I'M NOT IN A POSITION WHERE
I. CAN SUPPORT THE BILL BUT IF
THE- IF THE SUPPORTERS WOULD
LIKE TO MAYBE ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES WITH RELIABILITY
AND THE DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY
TO THIS- BACK WITH AGENCY- YOU
KNOW IT MIGHT. IT MIGHT HELP YOU
OUT. IN THE- START YEAH OKAY. SO
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO ADDRESS
THE RELIABILITY ISSUE AND THAT'S
WHY WE TOOK THE AMENDMENT TO
MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT
THE STATE BOARD SHALL NOT GRANT
THE- ARM THE MOCK UP I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S A IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT TO THE STATE PARTY
SHALL NOT GRANT. AN EXTENSION
ONLY IF. THE FOLLOWING
CONDITIONS ARE MET AND WILL THE
FIRST CONDITION. IS THIS
STATEWIDE ADVISORY- COMMITTEE
TASKED WITH ENSURING ENERGY
RELIABILITY- DETERMINES THAT THE
EXTENSION IS NOT NECESSARY SO
ALL THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ALL THE ALL THE
CONCERNS ABOUT- ABOUT-
UNEXPECTED WEATHER CIRCUMSTANCES
ANY CONCERN RELATED TO
RELIABILITY WILL BE ADDRESSED
BYE BYE SACRIS YOU KNOW IN
AFFECT THIS IS A SIMILAR TO.
SOME OF THE BILLS- MISTER PARK
THAT WE HEARD OF THE I MEAN.
LIKE MOST ABOUT IT AND THE SHIP
IS SAY IN FOR OF THE- TO SHUT
DOWN THESE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
POWER PLANTS YOU KNOW. I WILL
AMENDED MS REYES THE- THE
FINDING AS TO THE DEADLINE I
AGREE THAT- THAT- THAT IS- THAT
THAT DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THAT WAS INTENDED TO BE- YOU
KNOW FLEXIBLE. THIS IS A REPLY
ABILITY AND- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT I WILL MEN
THAT BUT IN TERMS OF- A
RELIABILITY THAT IS ADDRESS
THROUGH THE- REQUIREMENT AT ONLY
F. THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT
INCLUDES THE PVC THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. HI SO ONLY IF THE
SPIES RICK HE FINDS THAT NO
FURTHER EXTENSION IS NECESSARY
WILL- THIS BILL- KICK INTO
EFFECT SO IN IF IN EFFECT GOING
BACK TO MR QUIRK. I'M THIS. IS
GONNA THE THIS IS ALREADY. TO
SHIP DOWN BUT YOU KNOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE ALREADY HAD TO
EXTENSIONS WERE BOTH SHUT DOWN
BY THE END OF TWO TWENTY. STAND
TWENTY. AND NOW. THREE WE WANT
TO- SENSE OF A KICK IN UP A PULL
MATH- THE- TO RE AND THE FACT.
THAT THE SHOW HAS SAILED TERMS
OF THE POLICY THAT WAS ADOPTED
IN TWENTY TEN TO CLOSE DOWN THE
ONCE THE CLEAN POWER PLAN BACK
IN TWENTY TEN AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY- STAY WITH.
THE CONNECT IT THE ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY ISSUES ADDRESSED SO
THE IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY
THE SACK WAS ENTITIES STILL IS
MAKING THE ULTIMATE DECISION AS
TO WHETHER. THE SAP THIS IS
GOING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER- PLANT IS NECESSARY OR
NOT AND TO ENSURE ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY THAT THAT IS WHY
THOSE TWO PRIOR EXTENSIONS WERE
GRANTED AND THE EXTENSION FROM
FROM TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THEN THAT SET
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE HE WAS GRANTED
BECAUSE SAC WIS FACT AND THE IS
STILL. THESE UP PEAKER. YOU KNOW
I A BACKUP OPTION IN ORDER TO
ENSURE STATEWIDE A GRID
RELIABILITY SO ESSENTIALLY THIS
IS. CODIFYING WHAT IS ALREADY
TAKING PLACE THAT SACK WAS.
MAKES THE FINDING AS TO
ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY CAN CAN
YOU STRUCTURE RECORD CAN YOU
JUST SAID HIGHLIGHT WHO IS.
EQUITIES YOU KNOW THE JEAN
PUBLICITY HAVE NO IDEA YEAH I
CAN DO THAT CERTAINLY I MEAN
SEQUITURS- AS A- YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS EXPLAINS- THE STATEWIDE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON COOLING
WATER INTAKE STRUCTURES. INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE STATE
WATER BOARD THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THE CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A- SPECIFICALLY TASKED
WITH- ADDRESSING THE GRID
RELIABILITY CONCERNS I KNOW THAT
MISS BOTHWELL- ALSO DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN BUT BUT I THOUGHT I
THOUGHT THE BILL THAT COULD NOT
CHANGE THE STRUCTURE I THINK
UNDER THE CAR STRUCTURE SAT. I
RECOMMEND IN THE WATER THE WATER
BOARD MAKES THE DETERMINATION
BUT THIS WOULD CHANGE ITS- SACK
WAS MADE THE ACTUAL
DETERMINATION AM I WRONG ABOUT
THAT. YES I AM NOT SURE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING YES I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT MEANS YES I'M WRONG FOR
U. S. SENATE NOT ROCK BUT COULD
WITH CHAIRS IMPORTANCE COULD
MISTER WHICH HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY INTO.
GIVES THE DEFECTIVE DECISION. TO
SACK WAS. AS IF YOU READ IT IT
SAYS THAT THE STATE BOARD SHALL
NOT GRANT AN OPERATOR AND
EXTENSION. IF SACRIFICE AS THE
IF THE POWER IS NOT NEEDED. OKAY
AND I AGREE WITH YOU. ABOUT THE
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY BECAUSE IT'S
NOT IN STATUTE. THE WATER BOARD
COULD ADD ADDITIONAL ADVISORY
PARTICIPATES AT THEIR OWN AT
THEIR OWN DISCRETION THE WAY
THAT SACK WAS WORKS IS IT HAS TO
BE YOU UNANIMOUS DECISION OF THE
THREE PAGES THAT'S HOUSING EIGHT
TWO THAT'S VERY. BUT WHAT THE
AUTHOR DIDN'T. MENTION IN TO
QUESTION IT'S STILL DELEGATES
THIS IS ALSO THIS AUTHORITY TO
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND AS A
PROP TO THAT. THE TROUBLE.
THERE'S THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
REAL CONSTITUTIONAL. IT
APPROPRIATE DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY LIES IS GREAT BUT YOU
ALSO HAVE TO THEN GO GET THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SIGN OFF ON
THAT- THAT'S WHAT WE OBJECT YOU
FOR. AN OBJECT TO THIS WITH
BROUGHT. WHAT YEP TO. REFERENCE
TO A COMMITMENT IS THERE A
DOCUMENT THAT SHOWS ITS
COMMITMENT THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
COMMITMENT MADE BY THE WATER
BOARD SO THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE
THAT'S THAT IS TO BE USED ENOUGH
IF VENUE. THAT'S WHY JACK A
CHECK TO. LOCAL GOVERNMENT SORT
OF A VETO. I DON'T PERSONALLY WE
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH CYCLES
SO I THINK THE FIRST POINT YOU
MADE IS BEING CLARIFIED WITH ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS RIGHT. I'M CAN
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE FINDINGS
DECLARATIONS BUT NOT ON BOTH OF
THEM MR OF CUTTING IT WASHINGTON
COURT .COM ARE YOU WILLING TO
TAKE OUT BOTH THOSE THE- CONCERN
. DECLARATION WHICH ONE ARE YOU
SAYING THIS NOT ROOM TO. THEY
WOULD SEE WHICH SAYS ON OCTOBER
TWENTY FIRST DESPITE THE EARLIER
COMMITMENT TO REFUSE TO GRANT
FURTHER EXTENSIONS I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY COMMITMENT MADE BY THE
BOARD TO REFUSE TO. BACK TO THAT
. THAT WAS A COMMITMENT THAT WAS
DIRECT MADE BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO MYSELF AND TO SENATOR
BEN ALLEN WHEN WE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE EXTENSION OF
TO BE THE PLAN V. THE- WATER
BOARD. CHAIR STATED THAT- THIS
WOULD BE THAT THE FINAL
EXTENSION ARM. AND- ACTUALLY UP
WELL I'M NOT SURE IF IT WAS A
CHAIR IF IT WAS IT WAS- THAT
THEY THEN BECAME BUT A
COMMITMENT EIGHT WAS MADE
NEEDLESS TO SAY THAT THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS- YOU
KNOW ARE NOT THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE OF. WELL ME TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO CLARIFY ANY
OBJECTIONABLE AT AGE- THAT-
MISTER WATCHES SO UPSET SO I'M
GOING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND I MOVED TO BELL. OKAY
MANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY WELL I
HAVEN'T IN SUPPORT- THAT THERE
WHAT WAS YOUR SEX. THAT'S
INTERESTING ALL RIGHT HERE'S WHY
YOU SHOULD SUPPORT THE BELL. OF
THE WAY THIS IS SET UP WELL LET
ME ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY FIRST. OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THERE IS NICELY
ASKING OUR SACK WITH. THIS
AGENCY ARE TO CONSIDER CLOSING.
THE AGENCY STILL HAS THE FINAL
WORD SO AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
THIS REQUEST IF IT ENDS UP BEING
A REQUEST JUST LIKE FRANKLY
ANYTIME THEY WANT TO CITE A
PLANT A LOCAL AGENCY CAN SAY NO
WE DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD DO
WITH THEIR AND THEN INSIDE IT
TWICE I THINK THAT'S- THAT'S
REALLY CHANGING THANK. I AM
CONVINCED THAT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS- THAT- RELIABILITY IS
AGREED TO AND THE WATER BOARD.
REALLY WANTS TO SHUT THESE DOWN
I HAVE NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT AND
PROBABLY OF THE TIME WHOEVER
SPOKE WITH YOU- FELT THAT WE
WERE THERE AND THEN THEY CLOSED
DOWN A COUPLE NUCLEAR PLANTS AND
THIS HAPPENED AND THAT HAPPENED
AS LONG AS YOU'RE GUARANTEEING
RELIABILITY WHICH YOU ARE WHEN
IT GOES THROUGH SACK WAS NOT.
YET OUT AND I'M OKAY WITH THE
BILL IN THE END WHAT THIS. IS
JOB LEADING. LET THANKS. THAT
THIS SHOULD BE ADDRESSED I DON'T
THINK IT'S ANYTHING MORE THAN
THAT AND- HE COULD HAVE DONE A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
EASIER BUT WHATEVER I THINK THIS
IS FINE AND I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING THANK YOU SO FULLER IS
AMONG ON THE FLOOR IN. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YOUR SECOND. SECOND
SECOND TO GET- JACK CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY I AM. AGAIN I WILL
COMMIT TO A- ADDRESSING THE
OBJECTIONABLE LANGUAGE AND THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS- I
ALSO YOU KNOW WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT- YOU KNOW LOOK I I'M A
LAWYER I DON'T WANT ANYTHING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I THINK THAT WE
CLARIFY THAT THE- ULTIMATE
DECISION YOU KNOW CONTINUES TO
REST WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD.
BUT IT'S UP. I KNOW THAT IN- THE
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE NATURAL
RESOURCES THERE WAS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT. THE LOCAL. FORMAL
RESOLUTION BEING STRONGLY
CONSIDERED RATHER THAN BEING A
YOU KNOW A REQUIREMENT THAT IF
THAT WOULD. ALLAY CONCERNS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW OF A LOCAL
ENTITY. SOMEHOW I'M EXERCISING
POWER OVER STATE AGENCY THEN- I.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
DIRECTION THAT I WOULD LIKE TO-
TO- HAD TO ALLAY ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT TO. ABOUT THAT AND I WILL
COMMIT TO A MIXTURE TO WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF THANK YOU TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR I THINK DUE TO
YOU ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS ON
OF CORALINE OVERSTATEMENT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES- I DON'T
. A. B. FOR. SHE IS DUE PASSES
AMEND TO PROBE. EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON- CORREA. CORONA VOTING
CHEN CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM NOW FONG. FONG HI
CRISTINA GARCIA GIPSON. GIPSON
NOT VOTING HOLDEN. MAYES
MURATSUCHI HI MURATSUCHI AYE
CORK AYE QUICK AYE REYES. REYES
I SANTIAGO MEETING. IT WILL BE
THAT OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS THAT
ON YOU HAVE SECOND BILL THE
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I AM THE- NEXT
PRESENTING AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN- A BILL MOVED TO BELL. TO
TO SHED MORE LIGHT ON AND
TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION- TO-
ADDRESS CONSUMER INTERESTS AND
IN PARTICULAR TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS THAT- IS IT I'M GOING
WITH THIS CAN. AND OF HOW. RIGHT
R. AS THE STE I'M HERE TO TELL
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS- BILL
I PLEADED WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
WORKING GROUP AND BILL JULIAN A
FORMER A CHEAT SO ON OF THIS
UTILITY COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT
THINK PLEASE PROCEED HI BILL
ALLEY- ABOUT WITH BERMAN CAN
GROUP. OF STERN MERIT TO CHEAT.
SINCE IS ONCE MORE A- WE STILL
THINK IT DOESN'T REFORMS AND
TRANSPARENCY ACTIONS FOR THE CPC
AND THE CAL AYSO IN PARTICULAR
TAKES UP ON TWO THINGS WERE IN
NAPA SLEEP PASSED BY THIS STAGE
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND BY THE
GOVERNOR AMONGST IT OF REFORMS
THE B. WHERE THEY WANT. RESTART
LAWSUITS AGAINST THE PEACE THE
ONE OF HOW THEY HANDLE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST AN ALTERNATE
OVER TO MR JULIAN NOW. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MISTER MURATSUCHI
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR STARTING
TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT ARE. VERY
PERTINENT TODAY AND ARE NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY AND THAT HAS TO
DO WITH TRANSPARENCY IN THE
BASIC RELATIONSHIP CONTRACTS
COST DRIVERS FOR ELECTRIC RATES
IN CALIFORNIA OF THE BILL AS OF
UP PRIOR TO THE- ARE WAS A FAIR
WE- AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO
REAFFIRMING A LONGSTANDING STATE
POLICY AND FOR IN FAVOR OF
TRANSPORT. IN COSTS AS A-
MISTRIAL SAID IT STILL MAKES A
STRONG BEGINNING IN ADDRESSING.
THE ISSUE ARE BETTER. OF FOR
THIS COMMITTEE WAS SET FOR RATE
PAYERS OF FOR YEARS TO COME AND
THAT HAS TO DO WITH. ARE THE
BASE FACTS IT UP OF ABOUT
CONTRACTS ABOUT PRICE FORMATION
IN THE CALAIS SO THE TETRA AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION- ASK THEM TO COME
FORWARD. PHONE LINES READY TO GO
AND THEN- COMMENTS HERE IN THE
ROOM. HELLO EVERYBODY LEAH
BARRELS ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS WE
WERE IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
WE WILL REMOVE OPPOSITION WITH
THE WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL
GO NEUTRAL ON IT BUT WE DO WANT
TO GO ON RECORD AND SAY THAT
TRANSPARENCY JUST REALLY IS NOT
AN ISSUE HI SO ON THE PC HAVE
STRINGENT PROCEDURES AND
POLICIES IN PLACE AN OVERSIGHT
IN THISAREA SO AGAIN REMOVING
OPPOSITION THE AMEND. THANK YOU
HELLO. C. A. CENTER STANDING UP
ALREADY WILL JUST GO AHEAD TAKE
BOOKS THAT ARE IN THE ROOM
FIRST. AND THIS. TIME IS
DIFFERENT IF THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND I MADE IT WAS NO
SACRAMENTO SECOND ANSWER- TO
MOTIONS SECOND DOES HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION WITH AMENDMENTS
PLEASE HI GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBER
CHEN MEMBERS I ENJOY BECAUSE IT
OR SOMETHING. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THINK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DRESSING OR EXPERIENCE WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS- THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WILL BRING S. C. TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION THANK YOU. YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARCUS-
ON BEHALF OF PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHAEL MADNESS WITH
ANY- GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO WAS
IN OPPOSITION WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WOULD BE HAPPY TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC THREE SAME AS MICE.
I USE WE WERE IN OPPOSITION BUT
WE'LL GO TO NEUTRAL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US. THANK YOU SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM US MODERATOR
BUT ANYONE IN THE- PHONE LINES
WANTED TO. TESTIFY THE STATE
THEIR POSITION FOR AGAINST.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTEEN TO NINE ONE ONE IT IS
THE ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS A POSITION OR
SUPPORT. FOR AB T. NINE ONE ONE.
ONE DOWN ZERO. WE WILL GOAL
FELINE NUMBER SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS TRITON ON BEHALF OF THE
POWER CALIFORNIA AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND WITH
COMMITMENTS WE ARE ALSO REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO THE BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF SYLVIA'S TO LISA SHOP
ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WE ARE WE
ARE. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR.
THE THOUGHT HAD GOOD AFTERNOON
PAUL WOODS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
VISORS ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION-
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS AUTHORS
TAKING C. IS REMOVING ITS
OPPOSITION WE THANK THE AUTHOR
IN THE COMMITTEE FOR THE AND THE
STAFF FOR THE WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF IT IS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON IT. A. B. TWO
NINE ONE ONE IT IS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND I DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY KILLING UP RIGHT NOW ALL
MISTER TECH THANK YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE THERE'S MOTION SECOND.
TO PASS AS AMENDED CLICK CLOSE-
IF I HAVEN'T ALREADY MADE IT
CLEAR FOR THE RECORD I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
OKAY WHAT'S FOR ROCA. I HAD ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT VOTING
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE
FONG FONG I CRISTINA GARCIA
GIPSON. GIPSON HI HOLDEN MAYES
MURATSUCHI HI MURATSUCHI I WORK
I WORK I REYES. REYES I SANTIAGO
KING. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR THE MEMBER SAID ON WE HAVE
ONE PILL LEFT WILL LAST THE
DIGITS I HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT FOR. OKAY LASTLY- IS A
CALLED A MISTREATING BUT WHAT
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL GO BACK
TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA TO
BEGIN ADDING ON TO BILLS THAT-
MEMBERS HAVE NOT. VOTED OFF.
OKAY THE CAN FILE NUMBER. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED
CONSENT CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN
MAYES MURATSUCHI. THIS IS THE
CONSENT. MURATSUCHI I. REYES
REYES I SANTIAGO CHING. THAT'S
TEN IT UP AND LEAVE THAT OPEN
WELL THE MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN MAYES MURATSUCHI MESSAGES
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE TING.
SIX THREE WILL KEEP IT OPEN HERE
FIRST I'M SORRY THAT SEVEN.
THREE FIVE SIX SEVEN THREE. IT
OPEN ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN MAYES
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I REYES.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CHIANG. TING
HI. THAT'S A TO KEEP IT OPEN
WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN. HI I'M
NUMBER FIVE. AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN MAYES
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I THINK TING
HI THAT'S A ONE. THE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN MAYES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THINK TING I AND SEVEN THREE. I
DON'T NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN MAYES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THINK TING I TO LONDON'S- OKAY
WELL NEXT SERVE PRESENTER WILL
BE MISTER TEAM SERGEANTS BEACON
A TOUCH BASE WITH MR HOLDEN AND
MISS GARCIA ALL RIGHT MARCIA
SECOND. THE I AM DOES HAVE A DO
PASS AS AMENDED. THANKS THANK
YOU FOR. LET ME JUST THINK THE
GUY CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- RIGHT NOW
THIS BILL- MIMICS EXISTING
POLICY BUT FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ALL TYPES OF BUILDING.
THIS BILL AND IS THIS EAST. T.
THEIR EXPERTISE DEVELOPED THE
SYRIAN CONFLICT EVEY CHARGING
STANDARDS FOR ALL BUILDINGS
PRIOR TO FINAL YES THE ADOPTION
OF THE SO I THINK A CRITICAL
PIECE DOES WE MOVE AWAY FROM
DIRTY CARS INTO CARS SURE THAT-
EVEY CHARGING IS UBIQUITOUS AS
UBIQUITOUS AS ELECTRICITY. WITH
THAT WE HAVE ONE WITH US ALL
RIGHT KEVIN STONE STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA'S- AND
DISSOCIATION IN IT. POURED
BETTER IF.
I WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR. OPPOSITION
ANYONE ON THE PLEASE CALL FOR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIO FOR A
HAPPY CAL CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN OPPOSE
POSITION BUT AUTHOR AND STAFF
HAS BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH THE
SHARED SOME AMENDMENTS EARLIER
TODAY AND I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN GET NEUTRAL ON MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OKAY OVER THE PHONE
LINE. THIS MODERATOR. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT IS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
WANT TO GET OUT OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ONE DAY IN A ROW.
THEN WE WILL START WITH MY
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I BECOME MILE ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION IN THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ONCE AGAIN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP WITH ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND I DO NOT
SHOW ANYONE QUEUING UP AT THE
BREAK NOW MISTER CARE PLEASE
THANK THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK ANY QUESTIONS. COMMENTS
CONCERNS COMPLAINTS NOTHING OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THIS
TRANSCRIBER THANK YOU BROKE UP
PLEASE. I REMEMBER FOR AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
PORTER GARCIA AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING CARILLO. I
CHEN. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM II
FONG FONG I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I. MAYES MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
AYE CORK AYE CORK AYE REYES AYE
REYES AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
TING CHANG I. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ELEVEN REALLY THAT OPEN FOR-
A MEMBER TO COME AT ON YEAH WE
HAVE- MR HOLDEN'S HERE'S
ORGANISED GO BACK TO THE TOP
AND- GO DOWN THE LIST OF. ITEMS
TO VOTE ON. THANK YOU EVERYONE
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
CRISTINA GARCIA. I'M SORRY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA
GARCIA. HOLDEN HOLDEN I. MAYES
SENT THIAGO. AND SECOND.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HIDING TING I. THAT'S TWELVE OKAY A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT OF. GOOD JOB ON THE
CAN GO LOGITECH STOCK ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN. WE WERE
. THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN. HOLDEN NOT VOTING.
MAYES TING CHANG HI. THAT'S
EIGHT THREE KEEP IT OPEN. ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA
GARCIA HOLDEN. THIS IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. HOLDEN I
MAYES REYES LEADING UP. NINE TO
KEEP OPEN YES. THE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR A. B. TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHEN. CRISTINA
GARCIA MAYES STOLEN CONCERN. I
REMEMBER FIVE. AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN HOLDEN
NOT VOTING MAYES. STILL EIGHT
ONE. ONE I DON'T NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN. HOLDEN NOT VOTING MAYES
STILL SEVEN THREE. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I MAYES. EIGHT THAT'S THIRTEEN
ZERO AND THAT BILLS OUT OKAY
THAT BILL IS UP. OKAY START FROM
THE BEGINNING WILL GO BACK TO
THE TOP FOR. ROMP THIS IS THE
CONSENT FILE. ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I. MAYES THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT WAS OUT. I
REMEMBER ONE AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MAYES. THAT'SNINE THREE AND
THAT THAT WAS OUT. I DO NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I. MAYES REYES.
I DON'T KNOW. OKAY REPORTS OF.
THAT'S TEN TO AND A BILLS OUT
YOU. K. ITEM NUMBER NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHEN. STANA
GARCIA HI CRISTINA GARCIA I
MAYES. THAT'S TWELVE ZERO ONE
SOUTH ONE. ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA
. CRISTINA GARCIA I MAYES. NINE
I HAVE NINE ONE THAT BUILDS UP.
ANNOUNCED ABOUT THAT BUILDS UP.
HI TO NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MAYES. I HAVE EIGHT THREE
HOTELS GETS OUT. I DON'T NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IS MANDATORY
APPROPRIATIONS. MAYES THE BILL
THAT THE BILL IS OUT IN TWO ZERO
AT THIS TIME WE WILL- NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU EVERYONE.